this is a long-lasting insecticide
treated bed net
when used correctly it has been shown to
reduce deaths by 20 for children under
5.
it costs just
1.66
or about 30 percent less than the
cheapest coffee at starbucks
that's the thing about extreme poverty
the poorer someone is the simpler easier
and cheaper are the immediate remedies
life-saving vaccines and high-yield
seeds cost just pennies each when bought
in bulk
yet in the past 60 years the rich world
has collectively given 3.5 trillion
dollars in development aid to poor
countries
the marshall plan by contrast cost 150
billion in today's dollars
so where has all this money gone
why it is a problem for which we've
devoted so many trillions of dollars and
know of cheap solutions to remain
the obvious and seductive answer is
corruption
aid we're told ends up in the hands of
dictators who spend it on palaces
leopard-skinned hats and lamborghinis
if only this money actually reached the
people who need it these problems would
simply disappear
but would they
how do we know that corruption itself a
very real issue isn't hiding an even
bigger one
how do we know in other words that when
foreign aid does reach the intended
recipients it produces the desired
results
the only way to find out for sure would
be an experiment
and to dispel such an intuitive
assumption it would have to be
impeccable
staffed by the world's foremost experts
supported by many millions of dollars
and untarnished by ulterior motives
as it turns out such an experiment was
conducted for 10 years
starting in 2005.
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch this new exclusive
video about why china doesn't have any
allies despite for example its generous
foreign aid policy
in it we explore a deeper historical
explanation for china's international
aloofness
it's just one of a fast-growing catalog
of exclusive full-length polymatter
originals along with others on chinese
censorship kovet zero and china's rare
earth monopoly
watch all of them today for just 15 a
year with a curiosity stream and nebula
bundle
this is marie
like almost everyone who lives in
burundi one of the poorest nations on
earth with a per capita gdp of about
eight hundred dollars
she lives in a small rural village
why is marie poor
there are a hundred different macro
answers a lack of foreign investment
corruption red tape the absence of
property rights and so on
eliminate these impediments history
suggests an economic development
naturally progresses through a series of
discrete stages
a nation moves from agriculture to
manufacturing to services and
consumption
it's a known and predictable formula
the kind of rapid transformation
epitomized by east asia it's how you go
from here
to here in the span of a few decades
but before any of that can happen there
are a few prerequisites
starting conditions if you will that we
tend to overlook
you might say that the real reason marie
is poor is that she can't sell her
family's crops
she can't sell her family's crops
because there are no paved roads to get
to and from the nearest market
and there are no paved roads because the
area is infested with disease-carrying
mosquitoes
these very basic problems like
mosquitoes ultimately prevent burundi
from even reaching much less climbing
the economic development ladder it's
what you might call a poverty trap
you may have heard of it as something
like without a car you can't get a job
and without a job you can't get a car
in this case it's just much more extreme
so how does a nation escape this trap
how does one get to the first rung of
the latter
jeffrey sachs a famous economist and
director of sustainable development at
columbia argued the solution was quite
simple
instead of tackling malaria then moving
on to clean drinking water and so on
each of which he said was insufficient
on its own all of these things needed to
be solved at once
it was called the big push
to end extreme poverty in other words
you must address all the root causes at
the same time
after you've killed all the mosquitoes
cleaned all the water and build all the
roads everything else will follow
these steps are akin to clearing the
runway eliminating obstructions allowing
the plane to take off on its own
so confident was he in this theory that
he decided to launch an experiment
called the millennium villages project
in 2005.
it would begin as 14 sites in kenya
uganda tanzania mali and elsewhere
once these were successful he promised
they would become the proof of concept
for a giant global marshall plan to end
extreme poverty once and for all
not only would it not be very hard but
according to sax neither would it even
be expensive
ultimately he said this was an
investment not an act of charity
these massive life-changing upgrades to
health agriculture education and
infrastructure would cost just 120
dollars per villager
it was teach a man to fish in practice
at scale and without compromising on
corruption
it all sounded pretty intuitive
instead of just parachuting in free
stuff they would teach skills create
jobs and encourage the creation of
sustainable businesses
who doesn't want to believe that you can
permanently pull someone out of extreme
poverty and all for about a day's wages
in a rich country
it was a seductive idea
it also fit our preconceptions about
poverty
all these people needed was a little
outside help to get going on their own
each millennium village was guided by a
147 page handbook written by 29 experts
most from columbia university
it was the summation of everything we
know about alleviating poverty from
specific instructions to increase crop
yields to goals for community
involvement
schools were built ambulances delivered
clinics constructed clean water provided
and practically everything in between
crucially the project hired its own
teams completely bypassing corrupt
officials
but it wasn't long before the handbook
written in new york collided with
reality in rural africa
corn for instance was chosen as the main
crop in uganda for sensible scientific
reasons it's resilient nutritious and
not very difficult to grow
sure enough the first crop was a major
success with the average yield doubling
in only a year
in fact there was far more than the
village could possibly eat
there was just one problem
there was nowhere to put it
not only were there no storage
facilities but without any nearby
markets there was nowhere to sell it
without losing money
to make matters worse only after
investing 300 000 on the high-yield crop
did the project managers find out that
southern ugandans don't actually like
corn they called it prison food
realizing this saks scrambled to find a
buyer for the corn eventually convincing
the world food program to buy 150 tons
of kidney beans instead
this they thought was the key to success
commercial agriculture allowing the
ugandan village to sell its crops on
global markets
but to do so profitably it was
calculated the village would need to
produce three crops a year which
demanded much more water
unfortunately there was no nearby water
in this southern ugandan village
the closest source was over three miles
away which of course they had to walk to
get to much of it uphill
sax then managed to convince an american
company to donate 150 000 worth of pipes
to transport the water
but it was later discovered that just
shipping the pipes would cost another
thousand dollars
scrap that they decided and opted to
import eight donkeys to do the job of
transporting the water instead
despite all that work however half the
donkeys died of exhaustion after only a
few months
now each of these mistakes may seem
trivial and preventable on its own
the project could have simply asked
ugandans which crops they preferred in
advance for instance
but taken as a whole the theme is clear
there can be no true handbook to end
extreme poverty
there's no single universal formula
model or theory
time and time again the project ran into
unexpected hurdles
many of which would have been plain
impossible to anticipate never mind
prevent
the villages had no way to deal with
crime for example
nor was there a chapter for natural
disasters
like any human many of the villagers
sometimes acted in ways you might
describe as economically irrational
for example spending less money on
fertilizer than the handbook explained
was optimal
the project's managers were frustrated
to find villagers using mosquito nets on
goats rather than children
so much of its success depended on trust
for which there's no quick or easy
equation and in some cases had been
burned through early failures like what
happened with the donkeys
this is not to say the project was a
total defeat malaria decreased almost
immediately and primary school
enrollment soared
but when all was said and done one
independent researcher calculated that
it ended up costing twelve thousand
dollars per household lifted out of
poverty
for context that's about 34 times the
average local annual income
what's more we don't even know whether
those gains lasted after the project
ended in 2015 or if they were just
temporary
in fact it's hard to say how many of the
project's successes would have happened
anyway
without a control group the best we have
are estimates one of which concludes
that only half the purported results
were actually due to the project
some research goes a step further
suggesting aid often does more harm than
good because of unintended consequences
professor nathan nunn writes quote we
may have our largest effects on
alleviating poverty if we focused on
restraining ourselves from harming less
developed countries rather than fixing
them
tariffs and anti-dumping duties suggest
that aid is often based more on the
needs of the giver than those of the
receiver
now foreign aid is a broad concept and
some types like disaster relief are
unquestionably positive
the point is not that foreign aid can't
work but that right now it largely
doesn't
consider how powerful that 12 000 that
it cost to lift one household out of
poverty would be if simply given no
strings attached to that family
even if you just invested that money
giving the interest to the family
directly that would be at a five percent
interest rate six hundred dollars a year
forever
the unequal effects of climate change
will drastically increase the need for
foreign aid this century
so until and unless we discover that
seemingly mythical formula to end
extreme poverty it's worth asking
what if we just gave that 3.5 trillion
dollars in foreign aid directly to the
people who need it
at the very least rich countries could
stop imposing onerous conditions on aid
something china has often been held up
as a model example of
it offers money to developing countries
with no strings attached
yet for all his efforts china has few if
any friends
if its objective is to buy the world's
love it doesn't seem to be succeeding
there may be an overlooked historical
reason why china has such a hard time
making allies a fundamental difference
in the way it sees itself and others
and we explore that theory in this new
episode of my ongoing nebula original
series
if you're not subscribed to the nebula
and curiosity stream bundle you're
missing out on an additional fifty
percent of polymatter videos
these are full length exclusives and the
good news is that you can watch all of
them over an hour of extra content right
now for just fifteen dollars a year with
a curiosity stream and nebula bundle
on curiosity stream you'll find great
feature-length documentaries like don't
panic the truth about overpopulation
it's a refreshing breath of fresh air
about why we don't need to worry about
overpopulation
click the link on screen right now or in
the description to get both nebula and
curiosity stream for an amazing 15 bucks
a year and go watch the new original
episode over on nebula